bonjour marie dette tant pis bonjour
monsieur vialleton bonjour aux
auditrices et auditeurs de martine
première conseillère exécutive en charge
des affaires économiques merci d'être
avec nous ce matin
bien loin des tracas des bruits de cette
campagne pour les législatives
tout à fait enfin je ne suis pas partie
prenante puisque je ne suis ni candidate
ni suppléant
mais quand on regarde le nombre d'élus
de votre famille politique de cette
coalition en charge des affaires au
conseil exécutif à l'assemblée de
martinique on se dit que ces
législatives sont une occasion de fuir
cette usine à gaz que représente la ctm
non non pas du tout pas du tout on n'est
pas jeudi on n'est pas là pour fuir bien
au contraire il y a effectivement ddd
certains candidats qui peuvent
effectivement prétendre à d'autres à
d'autres actions à un autre est engagé
pour le job
non mais ça n'empêche pas en fait tout
dépend ce qui son conseil exécutif
effectivement devront démissionner mais
ceux qui sont à l'assemblée n'auront pas
démissionner de l'assemblée
c'est tout à fait compatible avec avec
la fonction d'audit et celles qui disent
que ce serait quand même bien qu'il
fasse ce job pour lequel ils ont ils ont
été désignés en décembre 2015 désir est
aujourd'hui pour ceux qui sont concernés
je pense que la la la ligne directrice
d'action est déjà bien tracé
donc on ne perdra pas je dirais
l'essentiel de leur travail commencé en
début de mandat très bien marrer les
torpilles conseil exécutif en charge du
développement économique le st de2 y
vient d'être adoptée en plénière par les
élus de l'assemblée on va rappeler c'est
un schéma territorial de développement
économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation
ce sont ces fameux plans schémas une
disposition obligatoire dans les
territoires pour penser pour concevoir
le développement économique c'est pas
fameux ses fameux sas à un terme un peu
péjoratif dossier
la façon dont vous le dites je sentais
effectivement c'était pas c'était pas
flatteur non non c'est effectivement
c'est un document qui ai demandé qui
était demandé à toutes les régions de
france donc à la cité un peu la
martinique et dans lequel on demande de
développer les orientations donc du
développement économique du territoire
sur les cinq ans à venir pour cadre on
sert on va tout à fait d'accord la suite
ce sont les sujets traités on était
aussi prévue par la loi un autre qui
donne des sujets traités donc on devra
traiter de l'agriculture de l'artisanat
de l'industrie de l'économie sociale et
solidaire de la coopération régionale
donc c'est vraiment on devra vraiment
faire le tour du développement
économique alors ce document il faut
quand même le reconnaître il été fait en
concertation avec tous nos partenaires
qui sont trouve sur notre territoire
c'est à dire les consulaires les opci
kacem cap nos esprits on reprend tout
simplement les plans inondant les plans
précis expliqué pourquoi parce que c'est
des gens vous demandent de faire ce que
vous pensez faire dans les cinq ans à
venir
ok je dis il ya quand même certaines
choses qui ont été faites on ne peut pas
dire qu'on est arrivé qu'ils avaient une
page blanche donc il faut en tenir
compte et proposer quelque chose
discuter avec les partenaires pour
trouver a donc pour arriver à faire ce
schéma c'est comment ça s'appelle
mais la réunionnité attendait non non
non non non donc avec le président marie
jeanne il a été décidé de profiter de ce
document pour faire de ce document un
vrai document de programmation
économique donc désaxé économies que
nous allons mettre en place donc ce sera
pas un document qui va rester dans
l'histoire comme le document sonore ce
sera plus fameux de gloire puisque la
première étape have a été validée
dernièrement et donc nous allons passer
à la deuxième étape
ouais mais à ce moment de mon
intervention je viens tout est quelque
chose qui m'a un peu dérangé lors de la
plénière une rom en commun fait
effectivement ce document n'a pas été
fait par un cabinet extérieur qu'on à a
fait qu'on aurait demandé à nous faire
l'audit et à nous faire le document vous
êtes fier que ce sera un truisme
martinique et je veux
awkward organique c'est vrai qu'avant on
avait souvent souvent on faisait appel à
ce cabinet metropolit et qui viennent
sur le territoire qui vous donnent à la
fin un document qui est un document qui
vous coûte très cher au bas mot déjà
c'est à partir de 150000 euros
et comme il n'y a pas toutes les
subtilités locales qui sont prises en
compte le document reste là or là nous
avons une équipe qui a été en était un
des administratifs en interne une équipe
qui était dirigée par marie-claude
dernier avec des personnes qui sont
embauchés à la 7e qui ont un niveau
d'études passe m'a dit qu'on va
apprendre des graphiques sur google il
faut quand même ne pas sous-estimer le
personnel administratif que nous avons
et nous avons donc cette équipe nous
avons des personnes qui ont fait de
grandes écoles
on a des personnes qui sont ingénieurs
nous avons des personnes autour des
matches de haut niveau spécialiste
ravailler à riscle madame dernier et je
termine et qui ont donné un document qui
est aujourd'hui quand même qui qui qui
au delà de générer de la même de la même
qualité que si on avait affaire à un
cabinet metropolit est sérieux alors
arrivé en décembre 2015 ce document
existant mais 2017
le mandat s'achèvera en 2020 le timing
2021 le timing ce sera quoi maintenant
alors ce document effectivement nous
avons un léger retard mais comme
beaucoup de régions que seul le
regroupement des régions donc on a eu
chaud martin qui veulent du concret oui
je vais vous expliquer non il ya eu deux
choses d'abord il a fallu qu'on précise
les grands principes
oui les grands principes de
développement économique que ne soit
filière la lore sur les ati l
organisation c'est que martine aurillac
non mais faut le dire il faut le dire
c'est la structuration des filières
tadoussac tuer notre économie en fait
construire notre économie avec la
structuration des filières deuxième
grand principe c'est effectivement ça
s'est joué sur une jambe de la petite
innovation et le numérique
rice est vraiment venir dans comme comme
outil dans la transformation
mais attention ça comme ça comme c'est
comme ma mère qui vient d'y remédier à
nos candidats non non non non me
souviens ton nom parce que jusqu'à
présent s'est pas fait alors c'est la
preuve c'est que il ne suffit pas de
croire que ce qu'on enfonce des portes
ouvertes après la masse à l'action je
termine troisième complice ip je vous
expliquer comment on va passer à
l'action donc troisième qu'en principe
c'est fait c'est à dire faire orienter
notre développement économique par des
appels à projets pour bien cibler les
secteurs que nous voulons soutenir et
aussi pour bien cibler certains
territoires qui doivent avoir une
attention particulière de là nous allons
passer plus nous avons validé le schéma
nous allons passer à la deuxième étape
la deuxième étape sur le plan d'action
qui n'est pas demander dont par par
l'état sur ce document mais que nous
l'aide que nous intégrons que nous
intégrons dans deux plans d'action ses
plans d'action qui sera attendait qui va
être décliné en action alors certaines
ou le réclamait déjà sur les actions et
à la population attendait ellis eckland
action tout simplement je vais vous dire
ce plan d'action on va faire exactement
ce qui est déjà fait à la réunion
je vais vous expliquer les actions et le
plan d'action va être déterminé avec
l'ensemble des partenaires parce que la
ctn à elle seule ne peut pas faire c'est
pas elle qui va tout faire et elle ne
peut pas dire vous ne pouvez pas faire
développement économique avec un seul
acteur économique
vous êtes obligés et pour en plus de la
cohérence et y avoir quand même travail
conséquent vous êtes obligé de le
construire avec l'ensemble des
partenaires
donc c'est ce que nous devons faire dans
les deux trois mois qui viennent
construire notre plan d'action
ces actions qui sont déclinés en actions
individuelles vont avoir la
participation des différents partenaires
il y aura un partenaire parmi qui va se
désigner comme pilote de l'action
suivant ses compétences et son big se
concentrent plus de la sq comme un art à
la crémade de ce schéma
oui on a un plan d'actions demandées par
l'état
ensuite on va mettre nos jours mais a
demandé par l'état le plan d'action
c'est pour ça que la niche le schéma
l'affairé en action plan d'action mais
c'est vous qui dites on a le document
maintenant on va faire cetera et cetera
ouais mais tout le monde dit qu'on a
fait tout le monde dit qu'on fera
qui est ce qui va évaluer ça alors voici
une bonne question bonne question mais
alors avec ce plan d'action c'est pour
ça que ça ne peut pas rester je dirais
une quelque chose de vide dans d'autres
mots nature ne dispense ou non non non
non il y aurait voulu qu'il y aura un
comité tout s'est en même temps que nous
faisons le plan d'action d'action nous
mettons place au comité de suivi et
d'évaluation qui se réunira tous les six
mois et qui fera un compte rendu sur les
différentes actions engagées et à savoir
si l'avancement est correct si à des
blocages lac sûr de vous mêmes qui ont
même vu par vous même ceux qui
succombent sur l'unité de suivi sera
composée des différents acteurs donc des
différents partenaires économiques et
aussi naturellement d'élus et qui seront
qui vont intégrer le comité et certains
experts que nous allons aussi intérêt
dans le comité et le compte-rendu tous
les 6 mois sera un compte rendu qui sera
publiée dont là pour la première fois on
va travailler en transparence et ce sera
je dirais de mourir parce que vous savez
on ne s'est pas fait entre 2009 et
déciderait en 2010 selon ce que je veux
dire c'est que jusqu'à ce jour on décide
de quelques actions on essaie de les
mener on regarde on bon là vous avez
vraiment ce schéma avec ce plan d'action
dont vous avez une vous dans les 3,7 des
trois grands secteurs prioritaires que
nous avons pris afin que nous avons
déterminé
nous aurons des actions dans ces
secteurs c'est dans la broye vie
environnement dans toute la partie
profession de la mer et puis le touriste
donc ce sera véritablement je dirais
bien déterminée bien écrit bien bien
programmé vous voyez bien programmé et
avec ce comité de suivi je dirai tout un
chacun pourra suivre l'action de la ctn
sur le diplôme les colonnes à l'école à
l'école élémentaire faisait de jolies
petites cerises prendre la page très
très très joli mais le peuple est
impatient laisser les acteurs
économiques sont impatients bernard
edwards président du medef vendredi
dernier il disait que à berne a
l'impression que les choses avancent pas
si vite que c'est avec eux il faut de la
méthode vous savez un peu si vous
avancez de façon des autres joyaux du
camp dit si vous jouez au pompier
notre territoire est un territoire qui
est assez complexe
il faut bien comprendre aussi la
structuration
de nos entreprises nous avons à faire
beaucoup de tpe il faut que la réponse
que nous allons apporter à nos
entreprises soient vraiment je dirais
soit soit soit profitable parce que si
nous apportons pas la bonne réponse nos
entreprises ne tiendront pas la route
donc on est vraiment à en a on a
vraiment la regarder quelles sont les
réponses que nous allons apporter et
notre nôtres et jeudi l'action que nous
allons construire et que nous sommes en
train de construire cette action elle et
elle est bien réfléchie pour répondre au
mieux à notre développement économique
on vous retrouvera dans six mois pur
produit tout à fait merci beaucoup moins
110 concerts exécutive en charge du
développement économique bonne journée
[Musique]